let's do a fake up you also do fake UPS
fake That's What I Call pretending
you're just waking up in a movie or film
and my wake up acting how do you know
that I do that you call it wake up
acting I call it fake up oh you've seen
you've seen this in something we both do
it
oh yeah great I didn't know that yeah I
do it we're both silly beans and we're
both obsessed with people in movies I
don't do it silly I don't know if you
know this but at this point I am an
award-winning dramatic actor as we see
it on Amazon Prime but I I wake up I do
drama wake-up packaging not silly oh no
what's silly is to do it no no no no
you need to understand
playing the game of doing a very
realistic dramatic wake up that's what's
silly not the wake up itself not when
you do it dramatically
I know what you're saying you don't know
what I'm saying and that's the
difference no I don't think you know
what I'm I know you're saying you're
saying the fact that that is even
something that you're doing yes the
drama of it no drama like a drama class
like the the acting the The Dramatics
I'm saying
no
I don't mean drama as in sad I mean I
mean uh like acting performing to
perform it what I'm saying is in the
same way that it's silly to be like I'm
gonna do a guy that's nervous to try new
things that's kind of funny can I show
you what I mean for an example and how
unsilly this is yeah but I don't I
should watch it and then tell me I'm
wrong but Rick I don't think the wake up
itself is silly this is why even the
situation of me doing it when you watch
okay do it okay can you just give me the
benefit of the doubt all right I still
don't think you understand I don't think
you understand go ahead you're about to
do a very serious fake up and when we'll
see fake up is silly because by Design
it's fake what
what is happening
to come by a huge yawn what I'm saying
is it's not when it's not fake and
you're in a situation yeah where you're
tired and you fall asleep and you wake
up
so I want to show you how serious it is
okay wait it's already begun
a little wink
let me show you how serious this is okay
will you do me a favor yeah will you
close your eyes sure you fall asleep but
don't peek I'm I'm also you're asleep
and you're gonna wake up before me I'll
tell you when to wake up okay
I'm not gonna peek
and I'm going to say call your name and
you just don't answer to your sleep okay
let me see
hey
you could wake up in 10 seconds I'm not
gonna tell you wake up in 10 seconds
Pete
I'm sorry sorry I forgot about your sock
roll I was so happy I wish you how
serious this is I was so happy I'm sorry
about the song let me show you how
serious this is that was just too good
hold on let me show you how serious this
is
uh you're awake now try to wake me up
okay I'm awake
wreck
wreck yeah
Rick
you're on a podcast man wake up
it's very good
oh [__] I'm so tired
what's up it's buried isn't it now you
know what I mean the whole time I just
wanted to say to you it's not silly and
you're like yes it is okay I wanted to
do this you know I don't like Pete just
let me do my [__] bit I loved it and
I did not know that's right that's
because I explained it like a dramatic
award-winning actor yeah that was very
good the trick is when you have
double-sided sticky tape to do two
layers so when you're done with it the
first time
you could peel it off and then you have
another one
ready yeah
I love that shout out to tear and kill
him by the way because I used to buy new
mustaches constantly and he told me
about double-sided sticky tape or toupee
tape if you are a redneck or you might
be a redneck if you don't you anyway uh
you stupid and uh and now I just I get
to reuse my mustaches all the time I
love that and I need it yeah well you
must
what do you mean
oh yeah
[Music]